hi there today we're looking at
addressing some limitations of
transformers with feedback memory
also known as feedback transformers by
angela fun tibo lavril eduard grav
armor joula and sunbayar of facebook air
research and
lauria on a high level this paper
as it says in the title it addresses
some limitations of transformers
specifically
of decoding transformers that are
trained with causal masking
and the problem is that these
transformers they don't make
use of all of the information they
compute
even though they technically could make
use of that information but they
sacrifice it
in order to train in parallel and we'll
see what that means
to alleviate this this paper introduces
these feedback memories and
thereby they arrive at a model called
the feedback transformer
that takes into account all of the
available information now this new model
it can't train as
fast because it can't be trained in
parallel as
the old model however
you can build models with this technique
that are significantly more
shallow so less layers and also the
models will
remember things for longer and this is
especially helpful when
multiple steps of reasoning are required
and it has to be done over
kind of a longer sequence so we're going
to see some tasks from
reinforcement learning and kind of other
sequence tasks where these feedback
memories
really make a difference in any case if
you
like content like this don't hesitate to
share it out and tell all your friends
about it
that would be awesome all right so
what's
what's the deal with transformers what
are they doing wrong as i already said
we specifically are in the case of this
sort of decoder only transformer right
here
these graphics here they are a bit
confusing on first
sight i've i found i had to dig into the
paper and read the paper
it was not necessarily clear from these
diagrams so i'm going to try to sort of
build up
what's wrong so what we're trying to do
is we're trying to do something like
language modeling
now it's not only language modeling but
in any case we have a sequence of inputs
which i'm just going to represent as
circles and what we want to do
is we want to predict whatever the next
the next circle is so these could be
steps actions to be performed in a
reinforcement learning world
these could be words of a sentence right
up to here and then you are supposed to
predict the next word
that's called the language model many
things
are fall into this category so
for example gpt3 is trained in exactly
this way
in order to do this you have to have a
model that somehow takes
all of these things and somehow builds a
representation
that then outputs this thing right here
okay
and that's you know good good in itself
um how
did we usually do it so the first
attempts at this of course
were sort of recurrent neural networks
and i'm going to go
over them here because they're going to
be important
even though you probably already know
what they are so
for actually for all of the models we're
going to look at today
what they do is they build
representations of this input data
so i'm going to represent this with
little boxes
what they do is they build these latent
representations right here
so the data in a recurrent neural
network flows like this
the inputs go up each time
into a hidden representation and this is
a neural network layer that does this
and then the hidden representations are
transformed into each other
so the first the first uh
the first input is input here then it is
sort of forward propagated to the next
time step
at which point the next input is
consumed and then
it is merged with the previous hidden
state and that is
propagated forward into the next time
step
and so on at the end you take this
representation and you
output whatever the next label is and
i'm going to purposefully draw this now
up here to say so the data flow is
something
like this there has been uh
improved versions of rnns that do
multiple layers of this so the next
layer
would be here and this is a multi-layer
rnn so if you like this could be an lstm
this could be a plane or an n and so on
what they would do
is they would do the same thing
here but then each hidden representation
goes into the next hidden representation
like this and these hidden
representations they
are also connected with a recurrent
connection
over time like this building sort of
like
a grid um right
so the way you have to
think about and then of course here in
this for so the output
of the last top right one goes into
predicting the next token or action or
whatnot
because the top right one as you can
maybe see all the information flows
up and to the right in this in this
case right here what this is what an rnn
does
now you can see this is very well
connected information however
if you if you think about this in terms
of information
flow if for example this
thing right here and this thing right
here
need to communicate somehow imagine they
need to communicate to solve the tasks
so what could this be
this could be for example a name frank
and this could be an like an article
referring to frank
like he okay and you know it's it's out
of order so but
in order to know who he is you somehow
need to
these two tokens somehow need to
communicate i hope that's
sort of clear now they here can
communicate by means of transform
transferring information you know from
kind of step to step like over here
maybe like this right and then in this
hidden representation
the information can be combined but you
can see the number of steps that the
information has to travel is fairly
large it can also be
combined here if the information flows
first up one layer
and then over and so on this is the
drawback of recurrent neural networks
very often the information has to flow
along many steps of computation in order
to be combined
with something else a different approach
is a transformer so a transformer
handles
sequences in a very different not a very
different way
but in in a different
enough way so a what a transformer does
is whenever it builds the representation
for
the next layer for example this
representation right here
a transformer will aggregate all of the
information
from the previous layer like this
so every one of these representations
right here
also this one it will aggregate all the
information from the previous
layer let me draw this in blue right
here
so all the information now
that's a lot better because now every
node can communicate with every other
node
in a matter of a single computation step
and
not just and not like as many
computation steps as
the two nodes are apart now
you need to help the transformers a bit
with positional encodings but
in essence uh this is a more powerful
way
of interpreting sequences and you can do
this
in many in many layers so the next layer
will have access to even more in like
so this representation right here it
will
draw information from all of the
previous
representations right here and this is
by means of an attention mechanism
and if you don't know what an attention
mechanism is i
watch my video on attention is all you
need i explain
how this works there but suffice to say
it
the information is aggregated over the
whole sequence layer
by layer there is a there is a
kind of a fundamental reason why this is
important namely
if we want to do very complex
computations
and by complex computations you can
maybe look at an example
right here where they have examples of
such a complex computation
in the appendix here they give this
example of code interpretations
there it is so what they give the
program as or the model to do
is this piece of text right here and
the the pro the model is simply to
go over this code and decide what the
output is
so you can see right here it has print
statements
and the model needs to decide what you
know what the output of the entire
program is
you can see right here it has if
statement so it has conditional
statements
as variables that are set but
also things like in decrement increment
these variables
then print them then update them again
have some conditions
on the variables right so there is a
condition between two variables
z and x so this is quite complex
for a model to solve and if you were to
let an rnn do this task because
the plane rnn it has you know it has
these inputs and it has one
vector that's the hidden state
everything needs to be saved in
this space of this one vector and
the longer it goes of course the more
noise you introduce and so on
so if stuff is very far apart like here
in many cases you need to keep track of
all the states of these variables
rnns tend to do sort of worse the longer
the task
transformers not so much transformers
can
look up so a transformer that ingests
this token right here
can look to any other token in a single
step
however in this task right here also
transformers
get at their limits because in order
what i said in order to do complex
computation you need multiple
layers a single transformer layer as a
matter of fact
a single neural network layer can only
do linear operations
right it has a non-linearity at the end
but you know everything's connected with
everything
in a neural network layer
right here so these are neurons these
are neurons and
this here is a giant weight matrix w
something like this this can also be the
attention matrix right here
um in every neural network there is a
linear operation
at the heart of the neural network layer
and a linear operation can only do so
much
notably it can't solve things like the
xor problem
and it can't do if conditions and it
can't do
um keeping track and updating variables
you know you cannot let's let's
break this down let's say we have this
text
x equals one x plus plus
um x
if let's say if x
greater than 3 then x
minus minus something like this
a transformer one layer will be able to
look at all of these at the same time
but it will
not be able to look at them in sequence
right it can only look at them at the
same time but it cannot say
it cannot have a dependence between them
it cannot say
oh because here i incremented
this is greater than three and then this
um happened actually it's not greater
than three but
uh and then this didn't happen it cannot
do that reasoning
can simply individually look at each of
these lines
and then somehow integrate them in a
linear fashion
so it could integrate the plus plus
as simply saying whatever x is i need
one more
and then it could integrate this and say
well x is one and then the two together
would maybe give you the result that x
is two but this
if condition and so on it cannot do that
in one layer for that you need
multiple layers with non-linearities so
by having multiple layers you could
a transformer could technically um
do things like have four nodes right
here and then these
the first node might you know combine
these two
and that sort of represents x equals two
now right
and then this node right here could
represent this
if condition x greater than three
and it could point i'm just imagining i
have no it could point to this node
for fulfilling the condition right and
then this node
here could point to x minus minus
right now i have a simpler program you
see i've done one layer i have a simpler
program
simply by linearly combining things then
in the next
layer i could combine these two things
and this one tells me x equals
2 and this one is x greater than 3 which
i can evaluate now since these two and
then
that might result in a weight of zero
right because
x is in fact not greater than three and
um
i could save sorry maybe here i could
save that weight of zero
right here so this node is now
representing zero
this node is still representing x equals
two and then this node
the pointer here this pointer
makes this um
yeah evaluate maybe to minus one
and then somehow 0.2 and then this node
i'm just making stuff up here this node
could somehow
connect these two right
this note could be representative of the
connection between these two and then in
the next layer
finally i can do my aggregation it's
it's then um
this and this get combined and then this
is
0 because because it's negative 1 times
and plus the 2 right here and then i get
it
my final x equals 2. i hope that
somehow it is not like it is not how it
happens
but you can see that if your only
if your only method is linearly
combining things layer by layer
um you have to go quite a convolved way
in order to achieve kind of multi-step
reasoning things and you can only do
this by having
non-linearities involved and one step of
reasoning
is usually kind of one layer with a
non-linearity
and thereby the number of steps of
reasoning here
is limited by the depth of the
transformer
if this is a transformer the number of
you know
kind of reasoning steps incrementing
decrementing a variable is directly
linked to
how many steps you do this uh
so that is that is a drawback
and that drawback can be solved with
these these memory things so let's
look at how a decoding only transformer
specifically is trained so again
here we said the transformer can include
things from
from anywhere but what usually people do
is they they do this causal masking
because we want to predict
every time we want to predict the next
thing right so
here we we have a sentence
right and then we make samples of it we
say okay
maybe if i input those two i want to
predict this one
but if i input those three i want to
and if i input those four i want to
predict this one
i can make all of this in one
if i set
my information flow like this
so i only
let the tokens have access to whatever
is behind
them that are these these decoding only
transformers
let me okay so
if you think of of this token right here
we just imagine that in order to predict
this token
we only have access to what came before
it like if you write
a book and you write the next word
you've only written the words
in front of it so we just say the
representation
of here only has can draw it cannot draw
information from over here that's
forbidden
we let it only draw information from
here
it's its own node sometimes like it
depends on how it's represented but
um only its own node and to the left of
it
the same goes for for
this one so like that
like that and this one here and then
this one
here it can draw information from here
from here
from here it can draw information
and this one can draw information from
here from here from here
so still you see the property of long
range information is still
here by means of connections like this
one
or this one however we simply cannot
draw any information
from the right all right and also you
see
how this information flows and the
difference between
a recurrent network and this one is in
these
lateral connections here do i have
another
here there is no connection here there
is no connection
in a recurrent network there is a
connection
within a layer you see that here
there is none but instead there are
these long range connections
from the last layers what's
even worse what's missing in both of
them
is connections such as
the following do i have another color
black okay this connection
so if you look at
this thing right here it can draw from
here
it can draw from here from
here and if we have the recurrent
connection we can maybe also say can
draw from these ones
but technically it should also be able
to draw
from this one right because by the time
i reach
to the prediction of the next node from
here
i can certainly compute uh this
representation up here
right like nothing nothing stops me
from building in a connection like like
this one
and that's exactly what these memory
transformers criticize
among these old style transformers they
only go
feet forward meaning they only go up the
layers
and they don't even have lateral
connections like
recurrent networks they only have
forward connections in the layers
and that limits the amount of steps you
can do
in computation
in contrast with the memory transformers
information can flow
i'm gonna draw maybe it new because
let's actually look at their diagram so
you can see right here maybe it's not as
confusing anymore
actually it's still confusing because we
need to introduce this memory
information can flow
all the way up and then down again so
i'm just going to draw two layers
right here
so information can flow like this and we
so the first step is the same right we
simply we have nothing here to look at
there is no no so we can only draw
information from the left
so that's all we can do the second step
so let's say we've computed the first
step
we've actually output a token like this
one and we now continue because we're
auto regressive we always
input whatever we we output um
what we now can do is we can do this
and this right that's what this
representation
can draw from in a normal transformer
but now we could
technically also draw information from
here because we've already computed
these things
in the last step the reason why
transformers usually don't do this is
now you cannot parallelize training
in a setting like we've seen before
oh wait i've destroyed it but in a
setting like we've seen before
you can actually train this whole
sequence in parallel
like all of the samples if i have five
tokens i can make five samples out of
that
and train that in parallel it's no
longer possible
right here because if i train it in
parallel
i do it in the feed forward fashion
however here
in order to have access to this
information i
have already had to compute the full
forward pass for that first sample
okay so that's the drawback right here
however
um it might be valuable to have that
highest layer information
especially since that was the one that
predicted the next token
okay so probably a lot of information
about that token is going to be in that
highest level
information whereas with the previous
transformer
we could only draw information from down
here
so we have access to higher layers of
representation
of the past and that means the
information can actually flow
all the way to the end like so
all the way to the end and then back
again all the way to the end
back again all the way to the end and
every time we have
access to the highest layers of
representation so we if we look at this
thing we can we could actually draw
from all of the representations we've
previously computed
so we could look at um hey
what's what was this token that's what a
normal transformer could look at as well
but we could also look at
what did this first layer at the sorry
the first token in the last layer
compute
we can we can look at that it's probably
very informative
so now you can see that the reasoning
depth is sort of unbounded because
uh here even though i have
maybe five tokens right here i can only
do two steps of
reasoning across it um i can only
you know one step of reasoning is one
layer
so i can like save learn to save a
variable
here and then learn to increment it
right here
but i can't do more but here i can learn
a function for
saving a variable incrementing it and so
on and
do that all of this processing with the
variable and then
the next thing comes around you know
maybe that's incrementing
i can look at
the end right here and that may be the
representation for the saved variable
and then i can increment it and store it
in this representation
and then the next layer can come around
and it can look at
this representation right here and say
oh you've
incremented it after you saved it
right so this is the current state and
then it can go ahead and
modulate it as well so we can do an if
condition
and the next thing can look at that if
condition can look at
the value of the variable and through
the layers here so it has
it has two layers of compute just to
implement that if condition on the
current value of the variable
whereas the old transformer would sort
of have to
start from scratch you can maybe think
of it like this the old transformer
always has to start from scratch
doing the okay here's how the variable
starts here's where it's incremented
here i'm going to do an if condition
whereas this transformer
it does the computation and then it can
sort of store
information in these higher layer
representations
and all the next steps can look at it
now if you look at the light blue thing
that's a lot of arrows
this amount of arrows this amount of
attention
connection would pretty much explode any
system and that's why this paper
simplifies that and here is where
the trade-off another trade-off comes in
so you can't train it as fast that's
number one
and number two is they say well
we're not gonna let you look at all of
these hidden representations right every
every square here is a hidden
representation what we're going to do is
for each token after the information has
passed and we've computed these hidden
representations
we're going to sort of mash them
together so we're going to
take the two and maybe also the token
embedding
and we're going to build one so-called
like a memory
representation of that token so all of
this
is now incorporated in this memory
representation
and the next layer what it can do is
instead of
looking at the individual
representations right here instead of
looking at them all of them
can instead look at this
sorry the other way around all of them
memory representation that first of all
it saves space it saves memory
and second of all you can also share the
key and value computation
of the attention mechanism
whereas only the query representation
goes
here with the with the different layers
so that's queries number two
that's queries number one okay so you
can share that
and then once you have once you have
those
you also build a memory from the second
token
and then the third token it can look
at both the memory of the second token
and the memory of the first open so you
still have that transformer
long range information pass but now
you have sort of a summary these memory
blocks right here
within each layer and that's exactly
what we see
in the diagram right here and that's
already the model so the switch
transformer
is a transformer that
forward propagates not in parallel
but token by token it forward propagates
then it builds this memory and then
all the next tokens they can
instead of paying attention to um
two things in their own layer like so
they can now
pay attention to previous
memories okay again the arrow
should go in this direction so that
is a feedback transformer
it retains the long range information
flow
but the information doesn't flow from
same layer representations
the information actually flows from
memory and the memory
is a weighted sum of all of the
representations
of a given token that includes higher
layers like this one so information can
flow from higher layers
in the earlier in the sequence to
lower layers to later in the sequence
and that allows
each sequence element to do as many
reasoning steps as there are depth
in as there are a number of layers
whereas in a normal transformer
the entire sequence only had
that many reasoning steps so here
reasoning steps are per token whereas
previously
the reasoning steps were per sequence
and that's of course
more powerful
yeah that is pretty much the model um
now okay i have i have one thing right
here
um one thing to sort of
remark namely you know they consider
the the rnn right here on on the right
like how
how it's different from the rnn you can
clearly see that the rnn
the information needs to travel many
many steps to arrive somewhere
that has been the drawback of the rnn
but people
have sort of solved this in rnns
using well you guessed it attention in
fact
attention mechanisms were first
introduced to help
rnns overcome this problem an rnn with
an attention mechanism
would look like something you're very
familiar to so
here we build these hidden let's just
consider a one layer
rnn for now we build these hidden
representations
okay and um
again it goes like this and then there
are these recurrent connections
right here that's an rnn but but
if we help this with an attention
mechanism
what we do is we say whenever you
compute for example this representation
what you're allowed to do is you're
allowed to also not only have you know
this connection you're allowed to
look back at the previous
hidden representations and aggregate
information
using an attention mechanism so that's
where a tension mechanism actually sort
of come
from in this domain and
if i look at this switch transformer
model
i very much just see a bit of an
elaborate
rnn so if you just
tilt this if you tilt this graphic right
here
you will see and we can do this together
so um
yes if you if you look at this and if
you tilt the graphic
so i'm going to draw again three things
let's do it down here i'm going to draw
three things but instead of going
up with the squares i'm simply going
next to each other
here three squares for this three
squares for this
and three squares for this right
representing the three layers
so before these here
they were in in this direction they were
up but now i've tilted them
to the right okay and
with the with the the way the memory is
built so
the information flows like this
and like this and like this right and
here
like this like this like this will fill
in the other connections
shortly
the memory is built from those three
so like this
from those three a memory is built like
this
and from those three a memory is built
like this
and now if you look at that
when you for example compute this node
right here what you're allowed to do is
you're allowed
to look back at the memories so you have
kind of connections like this uh
i keep drawing these arrows the way
the other way around right so this one
it draws it it attends
to the memories of the previous layer
and if you see this
as a recurrent neural network you are
exactly right
okay so um yeah i don't i don't
exactly know what to say this is an rnn
with an attention mechanism it's just
that these the in the construction
of the things you can attend like this
usually people just took the hidden
state of the rnn cell
in order to to um in order to do
what they attend to but now you
i guess you also drop the recurrent
connection
because you can only attend to the
memories so there is no
there's no you know kind of recurrent
connection but there is
a connection like this there is a
connection like this
no there is no there is a connection
like this like to the
things here yeah i guess okay
if if this it's a convoluted it's like a
halfway in between an rnn
and a transform because you don't
strictly have the recurrent connection
so you don't have
anything like right here but you do have
like this connection for example to all
the three things down here
so it's if you view this part
as kind of an rnn cell and this part is
an rnn cell and this part has an rnn
cell
then this is an rnn with an attention
mechanism
or something that's extremely extremely
similar and yeah the attention
mechanisms in
rnn actually do solve this this long
computation
problem that was exactly why they were
introduced and
they do solve it and at some point
people realized wait we don't need the
recurrent connections
actually and that's how you end up with
transformers
so this here is sort of the
the hybrid between the two right um
if you want to go further you can you
could actually think of making
multiple layers of these memory
representations
right and then you're you're sort of at
the same
um at the same
problem to start with kind of you recurs
into the problem
but yeah i don't wanna i don't wanna go
into that necessarily
so you can see here instead of up here
attending
um instead of the next layer
the next layer representation being the
previous
layer attending to all its sort of
layer um to all of its left
neighbors in the previous layer you will
have
you will have the same thing attending
to
all the previous memories and the
previous
memory is built as a weighted sum
over all the layers and the most
important thing for their model
is this thing right here you can see
that this
now goes over all the layers even the
layers
above the layer we are currently
computing
it's just that it's from previous time
steps all right
they also explain how you can as i said
share the keys and the values
that's not necessarily important but
it's just something you can do with this
model that you couldn't do
before because before uh not all the
layers were attending to the same memory
now you can do that so they demonstrate
this
on tasks such as language modeling
where you can see blue here is the
classic transformers
and these are different sizes so to the
right you kind of go
shallower in the transformer and you can
see
as you go shallower so as you have less
layers
the decoding speed increases for both
of these models however the transformer
model the classic model
it sinks in performance a lot more
than the feedback transformer thanks to
those feedback connections
however you know here you can see and i
would bet maybe if you go to the left
here that the
classic transformer would beat the
feedback transformer
simply because the feedback transformer
isn't
a generalization so it also needs to do
this trade-off
so it trades off speed down here
and also it trades of sort of mixing
that memory
they have a very interesting by the way
this is reinforcement learning
uh where you need to remember things for
quite long
and that is also a domain where they
excel
at so here they actually look at
the different kinds of memory and these
are a bit deceptive down here i think to
to have the whole impression you need to
do this over
multiple time steps and actually uh
kind of see how they develop and then
you can see more clearly
but you can see that their performance
so this here is the feedback
transformer and this here is kind of the
original transformer where you can see
it only goes up the layers
they they see here that if you introduce
recurrent connections that helps a
little bit
but not too much because the only thing
you gain basically is this lateral
connection here
that you didn't have before however if
you do
top only meaning that you can attend
to the previous time step only to the
topmost representation so whereas before
you could attend only to things below
you or at the same height as you
now you can only attend to the topmost
so information like flows like this
and then can flow down again and then
flows up again
if you do that you get almost all
of the performance of the feedback
transformer i hope you see this so here
lower is better
and um this is all this is without the
memory
actually this is you know every
everything like this is the
the full generalization i talked about
you get almost
all the way there by doing top only
attention
so the reasoning why they do this the
fact that the
regular transformers they don't have
access to that
last to these higher layer
representations in the next
um steps of computation i think that's
really valid
so you know you know like experiments
here on reinforcement learning in
in grid world they're fun um not
necessarily i don't necessarily believe
all experiments in in papers but this is
a finding that
that does strike me as
quite fundamental and it validates their
claims
and they have other experiments where
they show
that they try this sort of top only
attention but they it's not
top it's you know they choose a layer to
which
you can attend to to the representation
of which
that the next tokens can attend to and
if they say you can only attend to layer
one of the previous tokens
you you do get um pretty
bad kind of performance or bad well
worse than
and you see as you go up the layers up
the layers
you get better and better performance
so here is where you average all which
is almost what they do
the feedback transformer is a it's a
learned average
right it's a learned it's a weighted sum
and the weights you can learn
um in fact if they go to the last thing
here
they do almost get there so i don't know
you know that could be experimental
noise i totally believe that you know
you can get gain a little bit
by doing this you know feedback
aggregation but you can see
if you are only allowed to attend two
layers like five and six here you're
already doing
fairly fairly well and this is a
summarization task so this is a language
task this is not a
constructed task like their rl tasks
and that is fairly convincing i would
say
the trade-offs are evident they have a
table somewhere where in training they
are much slower
however on inference actually they can
speed up quite a bit because they share
a lot of the weights among layers that
others
don't yeah so here you can see for
example in language modeling the
original transformer has
much higher speed this is i think tokens
per second
than the feedback transformer however
the feedback transformer in the
inference speed
is much faster than the original
transformer because at
inference both models need to do it
token by token
because they are auto regressive whereas
in training time the original
transformer can do it
in parallel where the feedback
transformer has to do
again token by token because
they always have to compute all the
layers for one token
before they can go to the next token
they have some more experiments where
they show
that as as you decrease the memory
so if you sort of constrain these models
the feedback transformer performs
much better than the original
transformer they also compared to
lstms i believe and this is on these
kind of
sequence tasks that you come up with to
see sort of the properties of your model
so does this mean we can replace
transformers
probably not if you can afford
to build a large enough transformer that
will probably still
outperform the feedback transformer and
it will train faster which can be quite
important
however if you have very special tasks
where you need
long-range dependencies or really
multiple steps of non-linear reasoning
or are constrained in your resources and
do actually have the time to train it as
a trade-off
then the feedback transformer might be
something for you
all right that was it for me thanks for
listening share it out i'll see you next
time
bye bye